So I'm at the airport right now if you haven't noticed this is probably gonna be the best flight of my life
And it's also hopefully gonna be the people who are on board their best flight ever I partnered with Nintendo and Southwest
To give everybody onboard a Nintendo 3DS, and a copy of the new Super Mario maker for 3DS
This is Gonna be so much fun
I'm so excited
Okay, let's board [oh] by the way uh you guys remember Adam, Adam. [oh]
I'm here. I just looked like this is gonna be incredible. Yes, turn your 3D guess on we need this your pass
Let's go. Let's go cheap ass
We're about to bored
Hello, everyone [Sami]
Mario
Let me introduce you to a princess. Oh, that's a game [vintage], but an ethernet the princess her name is
ijustine hello
You guys hear me
Okay, this is cool
I've never used before so I'm justine and I make youtube videos and I'm a huge to nitendo fan bear special announcement for you guys
Everybody on this plane. Thanks to Southwest miss endo. He's all getting
Nintendo 3Ds, Xl
Who's a nitendo fan?
Like that I would [against] waters phew
you
somebody if I was on this flight, I was [white] [when] I am on this plate, but if I was sitting here, and
The surprises I got I got aboard
All right
What is your agenda huncles my new best friend?
back
Okay, so there is one last prize. I know we've been talking about Mario
Just a little bit [availing] a lot, but I am even more excited to let you guys know but at Lax
Mario
I need to preach you guys so you guys want to do a
Photos yeah, this is the best day ever to think [you're] making my dreams
Happy holidays
Pretty cool is flight ever but to make the flight even Cooler Mario is advocate
He's going to be here ready and [waiting] oh my God
You gonna take a selfie mario because this is very important for the social Media. Yeah, okay?
Okay, ready. Oh, you don't fit in my street
Okay, that's good. Yeah. Thank you so much
It's him. It's you Mario. Oh
That's so cool. This was so much fun
[I've] also Gonna put a link in the description
since we had so much fun [on] [this] flight you guys can actually win some really cool fun prizes from Southwest Nintendo like in the
description [check] [it] out